nous en tant que parents la peine elle a
vie oui mais pour avoir une petite un
petit apaisement de la peine il faut de
la prison la prison ferme aux États-Unis
tu tues quelqu'un sous l'effet de la
boisson c'est minimum 10 ans de prison
retrait du permis av ici c'est on va
jouer au B on a un
sur la plupart d'entre nous l'utilise
tous les jours en oubliant qu'elle tue
des milliers de personnes chaque
année soit un passionné ou un simple
utilisateur on préfère occulter à quel
point la voiture peut faire basculer une
vie Stéphane Martine chacun a été frappé
dans sa chair par un accident de la
route la vie de Stéphane a basculé le
jour où il a été victime d'un accident
depuis il est handicapé martineelle a
perdu son fils tué sur les routes de
Belgique elle tente de retrouver le
coupable comment un simpleyen de sport
peut-il condamner autant de destins j'ai
eu envie de partir à leur
rencontre je m'appelle Martine mafort
j'ai 52 ans et mon fils a été tué sur la
route je m'appelle Stéphane gervez j'ai
25 ans je suis paraplégique à la suite
d'un accident de la
route Martine maffor Stéphane gervez
elle a perdu son fils de 25 ans lui
l'usage de ses jambes tous les deux
essaient de reconstruire leur vie sur de
nouvelles bases elle dans sa ville de
bastonne en Belgique lui à Saint-Germain
en Laé en banlieu
[Musique]
parisienne
pour qui sont ces fleurs pour
[Musique]
David David c'est le fils de Martine tué
par une voiture la nuit du 10 juin 2011
sur le bord de cette route qu'il
longeait à pied à 100 m à peine de chez
lui vient toutes les
semaine c'est
dure c'est très dur de venir
ici mais c'est le seul endroit où où je
sens que mon gamin est
là c'est le seul endroit où où je viens
lui
parler je lui demande de
m'aider Martine recherche toujours
l'auteur de l'accident un chauffard qui
après avoir tué son fils a pris la
fuite je lui dis aussi que maman est là
qu'elle se bat pour que son âme soit en
paix je chercherai gamin je retrouverai
celui qui a pris ta vie
[Musique]
bonjours cette nuit-là je dormais quand
on a frappé très fort à la porte j'ai
senti qu'on allait venir me dire que
David était mort je suis descendue par
la fenêtre j'ai vu deux policiers ma
tête se serrait comme un ÉAU j'ai senti
le sang se vider de mon
corps j'étais comme morte ils m'ont bien
confirmé que David était
mort la vie de Martine vient de basculer
son fils qui rentrait d'un bal de
village est
décédé les policiers lui explique qu'un
couple était présent sur les lieux voici
leur
témoignage
un couple rentrait chez eux ils ont vu
une forme à terre ils ont évité cette
forme à terre ils se sont
arrêtés David n'était pas blessé n'avait
pas l'air blessé il respirit son ventre
bougeit le couple aurait alors garé sa
voiture sur le côté derrière le corps de
David toujours en vie mais à ce moment-l
un autre véhicule serait
arrivé le monsieur dit qu'il a fait de
de grands signes pour que ce véhicule
s'arrête ce véhicule n'avait pas l'air
de ralentir ni de
s'arrêter pour sauver sa vie à lui il
s'est jeté sur le côté ce véhicule n'a
pas dévié de sa route et a écrasé mon
fils ce soir-là David décède le crâne
percuté par la roue d'une
voiture mais Martine doute de la
véracité du témoignage du
couple cette voiture ne s'arrête pas
continue son chemin David est au milieu
de la route en travers de la route et
cette voiture ne dévie pas de sa route
alors comment ça se fait que mon fils
n'a que la tête écrasée je ne comprends
pas Martine se sent délaissé par la
justice qui négligerait certaines
preuves selon elle les prélèvements
d'ADN et les vêtements que portait David
ce jour-là aurait été égaré par les
enquêteurs les vêtements de mon fils
sont introuvables où sont passés les
vêtements de mon fils je ne sais pas
éventuellement si on trouve un véhicule
avec des fibres ou un morceau de
vêtements on ne peut même pas le
comparer avec ce de mon fils parce que
les vêtements ils ont disparu submergé
par des questions sans réponse Martine
ne dort plus ces deux autres enfants ne
supporte plus de vivre dans la maison
familiale remplie de souvenirs ils
partent vivre chez leur père d'avec qui
qui elle a divorcé peu de temps avant la
mort de
David le petit mon dernier avait 11 ans
sans arrêt il me poser les questions
maman est-ce que celui qui a tué mon
frère va venir aussi me tuer il a
préféré rester chez son père on était
une famille heureuse dans une maison où
il y avait la joie de de vivre des
enfants et tout à coup à l'AUE de mes 50
ans ma vie a été
brisée
depuis Martine vit seule dans cette
grande maison où habitait jadis 5
personnes dans une pièce la pièce de
David comme elle la nomme martine a
réuni les derniers souvenirs de son fils
disparu tous les jours je viens
regarder ce
dessin celui-ci ce personnage il
appelait
heureux une boîte remplie des trésors du
jeune homme souvenir d'une vie joyeuse
et heureuse il y a une cassette où il
écrit oral sur la guerre 40 45 moi et
mon papi c'est précieux c'est sa parole
ça voix mais je n'ai pas d'appareil pour
écouter ça et je sais pas si j'aurais le
courage d'écouter
ça c'est comme si j'étais avec mon
fils c'est ici que j'ai rassemblé ces
petits secrets ces dessins
il est là il est avec moi ça ça me fait
du bien des livres des dessins des
objets mais aussi son journal intime
dans ce dernier des extraits difficiles
à lire pour Martine sauf un passage Jam
parce qu'il écrit j'agis hélas parfois
donc j'assume et je suis il y a
quelqu'un qui devrait assumer celui qui
a pris sa
vie
[Applaudissements]
je ne peux pas rester sans savoir parce
que ça c'est pas vivable ce qui me tient
envie c'est de chercher et d'avoir
l'espoir qu'un jour je vais savoir parce
que je dois savoir j'ai le droit de
[Musique]
savoir Laur vousêtes avocat à écouter
Martine on a l'impression que l'enquête
a été baclée c'est quelque chose qu'on
entend souvent dans les accidents de la
route avec déite fite c'est une réalité
c'est vrai qu'on a souvent des dossiers
qui sont faits de manière très
artisanale et peut-être que la police la
gendarmerie n'a pas tous les moyens
d'investigation modne dire c'est vrai
qu'on a très peu d'experts en France
aujourd'hui qui travaillent avec tout ce
que l'informatique et la criminalistique
contemporaine peut apporter on est loin
de ces séries américaines et experts qui
trouvent la solution à chaque fois n est
pas encore encore relativement loin bien
qu'il y a d'énormes progrès qui ont été
faits mais sur ce qui concerne les
accidents de la circulation routière il
reste beaucoup de progrès à faire quel
est le problème c'est un problème de
formation de je pense que c'est un
problème de moyen avant tout parce que
ça suppose évidemment des moyens et puis
ensuite puis peut-être de formation mais
nous pouvons tous un jour être
responsable hein d'un accident qu'on
peut qualifier d'involontaire un
obstacle sur la route et cetera là c'est
vraiment l'homicide involontaire B c'est
l'homicide involontaire mais à ce
moment-là encore une fois je crois qu'il
faut assumer c'est-à-dire celui qui
téléphone pendant qu'il roule alors
qu'on sait que c'est peut être un
élément de distraction essentiel bah
s'il commet un accident bah je crois
qu'il faut qu'il assume aujourd'hui on
est dans un état de droit les lois
doivent être appliquées et ceux qui ne
respectent pas les lois doivent être
condamnés en
conséquence mois passe l'enquête est au
point mort Martine vit seule dévastée
mais elle va bientôt retrouver la force
de se
[Musique]
battre la place ou
quoi j'ai peur de ne pas
pouvoir me garer
ici je vais me je vais me garer comme un
sauvage en
fait si Stéphane se permet aujourd'hui
de se garer au milieu du parking c'est
qu'il a besoin d'espace pour sortir son
fauteuil roulant car il y a 2 ans
Stéphane a été victime d'un terrible
accident de la
[Musique]
route rentrer chez moi en moto super
calme et euh en fait arrivé à un feu moi
j'avais le feu vert quelqu'un en face de
moi avait le feu vert aussi et tournait
sur sa gauche en fait il a grillé la
priorité j'ai perdu le contrôle de de la
moto en freinant et j'ai été percuté un
trottoir par la tête dans le choc en
fait ma ma colonne s'est plié un peu
comme un spaghetti un spaghetti dur que
tu essayes de faire rejoindre les de il
casse j'ai perdu connaissance sur le
coup c'est les pompiers qui m'ont
réveillé sur place tout de suite j'ai
ressenti la douleur atroce dans le dos
les pompiers me demandaient est-ce que
tu sens est-ce que tu sens quelque chose
je sentais plus rien apparemment
j'aurais dit à mon père que j'allais
plus remarcher j'ai percuté assez vite
qu'il y a quelque chose qui allait pas
et que c'était au niveau de la
colonne VO l'atteinte à la moelle
épinière est sévère et irréparable
Stéphane ne sent et ne contrôle plus
aucun muscle du haut de la poitrine
jusqu'à la pointe des pieds il est
paraplégique désormais en fauteuil
roulant sa vie bascule
définitivement tout a
changé tout a changé parce que voilà
déjà je me lève le matin quand je me
réveille j'ai le fauteuil à côté de moi
faut se convaincre voilà que le matin
quand on se lèveah c'est pour aller dans
le fauteuil et puis on y passe toute la
journée
donc
finalement au début
c'est c'est comme une paire de
chaussures qu'on qu'on ne supporte pas
et qu'on est obligé de mettre voilà au
début c'est comme
ça 11 mois de convalescence 11 mois
durant lesquels stéphane est transféré
d'hôpital en hôpital durant cette
période il se lit d'amitié avec sa
kinésithérapeute une relation amoureuse
née alors entre le patient et et sa
thérapeute de fil en aiguille bah on
s'est on s'est mis ensemble on s'est mis
ensemble c'est une histoire assez
commune en fait il y a beaucoup de kinés
qui qui finissent par se marier avec
leur leur leur patient il nous voit
combatif en fait il nous voit évoluer
donc il nous voit dans une pente
positive quand nous on est dans une
pente négative donc en fait on est
séduit par ça des deux côtés quoi à sa
sortie de l'hôpital Stéphane retourne
vivre chez ses parents et sa famille
doit s'adapter à son fauteuil roulant la
relation en fait avec mes parents et ma
petite sœur se sont
dégradé parce que c'était très difficile
en fait ils étaient derrière moi à me
motiver à me pousser à me forcer à faire
plein de choses quand je me levais le
matin on me demandait est-ce que ça va
quand quand j'étais dans la salle de
bain et puis qu'ils entendaient plus de
bruit il me demandaient est-ce que estce
que ça va j'en ai eu marre qui me
demande toutes les 10 minutes est-ce que
ça va est-ce que ça va donc en fait
c'était plus vivable et puis moi je moi
je rejetais un peu la faute sur tout le
monde donc j'étais pas pas agréable du
tout avec eux et donc finalement j'ai
quitté j'ai quitter la maison je suis
venu m'installer ici avec ma
copine désormais en couple Stéphane peut
commencer à se
reconstruire les gens me disent dis tu
verras un jour de toute façon tu vivras
avec tu accepteras et en fait moi je
pense on naccepte jamais en fait on
naccepte pas d'être en fauteuil mais on
s'y fait voilà donc aujourd'hui je m'y
suis fait j'accepte pas mais je m'y suis
[Musique]
fait aujourd'hui Stéphane doit faire une
course en ville le magasin est à moins
d'un km mais c'est en voiture qu'il
devra y aller et comme pour chaque
déplacement le même long
rituel une fois au volant de sa voiture
adapté à son handicap stéphane est libre
de se rendre seul où il veut j'ai un
cercle derrière le volant là qui me
permet
d'accélérer et là une poignée de frein
donc quand j'accène la poignée de frein
vers le bas ça
freine hop bon va falloir demander ouais
s'il vous plaît euh je cherche une
sangle
ouais
Ty de type élastique uniquement
élastique ouais alors il m'en faut une
large parce que c'est pour faire le tour
d'un fauteuil de sport pour me tenir en
fait dans le fauteuil d'accord on va
faire le tour du fauteuil c'est bon et
on va éviter les poignets ouais
nickel
là je peux la RER encore si je veux donc
nickel ça convi ouais merci hopon
courage Stéphane vient d'acheter une
ceinture de maintien dans un magasin de
moto il s'en servira pour son quotidien
en fauteuil une ironie du sort pour un
ancien motard quand on est motard on
passe pas mal de temps dans les magasins
de moto les nouveautés nouvel équipement
voilà pour l'entretien de la moto
c'est sympa et aujourd'hui de revenir
comme
ça
bah il y a toujours la même sympathie
donc
c'est que du plaisir que du plaisir
c'est ça fait un petit quelque chose de
se dire qu'on vient pas pour pour la
moto
mais mais ça
va
[Musique]
Gérard Lopez vous êtes psychiatre en
2012 3645 personnes ont trouvé la mort
sur les routes en France ça signifie que
chaque jour div sont fauché c'est énorme
767 victimes en Belgique la oou viille
Martine et pourtant chaque nouvelle
limitation de vitesse fait l'objet de
vif critique de votre point de vue de
psychiatre comment expliquer cette
réaction bah écoutez moi même quand je
reçois une contravention parce que je
roulais à 56 à l'heure au lieu de 50 ça
m'énerve c'est une réaction infantile
narcissique voilà une réaction de colère
immédiate et on trouve vraiment
scandaleux de se faire verbaliser pour
un petit kilomètre supplémentaire c'est
évident mais on est obligé de constater
que ça a fait énormément diminuer le
nombre d'accidents donc il faut se
résigner à ce que la peur du gendarme
soit efficace on a un peu un sentiment
de toute puissance sur la route oui bien
sûr on est protégé et puis il y a pas le
contrôle social on devient violent on
insulte les gens bien protégés en sa
petite bulle hein on a l'impression que
notre conscience du danger est amoindrie
sur la route je me crois que les êtres
humains se pensent immortel vous pensez
immortel je me crois immortel ça
n'arrive toujours qu'aux autres donc la
prise de conscience extrêmement
difficile et parfois c'est après
l'accident que l'on prend conscience on
le voit dans le documentaire ce sont les
gens qui ont été personnellement touchés
qui forment des associations qui
essayent de faire évoluer les choses
vous savez c'est pas pour rien qu'en
France la Ligue contre la violence
routière a été créée par une journaliste
de la croix dont les les enfants ont été
victime d'un chauffard c'est toujours
comme
ça depuis sa sortie de l'hôpital
Stéphane se déplace en fauteuil roulant
il a dû arrêter ses études en radiologie
et va découvrir qu'il peut malgré tout
donner un nouveau sens à sa
[Musique]
vie chaque jour Martine traverse la
frontière entre la Belgique et le
Luxembourg voilà Paul pour rejoindre le
restaurant dont elle est propriétaire
depuis 10
ans coca ici c'est mon établissement TR
TR café
restaurant gérer son commerce une bonne
raison pour elle de se lever le matin
malgré la mort de son fils il y a 2 ans
sur une route de
campagne il faut travailler et le
travail ça on s'en sort ne pas rester
enfermé chez
soi se battre voir du monde bouger
travailler se donner des activités c'est
très important bonjour après l'accident
Martine n'est pas venu travailler
pendant un an une absence qui a entraîné
une baisse d'activité du restaurant
bonjour Aujourd'hui Martine est sur les
dans 5 minutes on fait ça de suite merci
mais au début la reprise était difficile
je me précipité
ici je vis dans ce petit coin
pleurer ple fort et alors vous voyez à
ce momentl la dame trava en cuisine les
autres il rentrent leur tête ils ont mal
au cœur il savent pas quoi
faire
au sein de son établissement Martine se
sent bien entourée bonjour Marc
notamment grâce à Marcelle
elleveuse elle travaille ici en elle me
connaî depuis l'enfance elle mène un
gros combat tout en restant
toujours très forte elle a changé après
cette nuit du 11 juin oui beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup énormément ce n'est
plus plus la Martine
d'avant c'est une femme souriante
joyeuse fau folle maintenant c'est plus
qu'une façade tout ce que tout ce
qu'elle
a David venait souvent prêter main forte
à sa mère au restaurant une absence qui
reste difficile à vivre pour certains
habitués il restera dans mes
souvenirs et la photo mais mais à la
photo de mon fils qui ne le quitte pas
dans son portefeuille il était devenu un
copain ici derrière lui
et là derrière le comptoir une photo de
david et sa mère est accrochée au mur
une photo pleine de souvenirs cette
photo elle a été prise ben si vous
regardez le mur elle a été prise ici
c'est la dernière photo que j'ai avec
mon fils c'était le 13 février c'était
le jour de mon anniversaire 4 mois avant
sa mort je me rappelle il me tenait par
l'épaule et il me disit comme tu es
belle maman 50 ans ne le dit à personne
tu en fait 10 de moi voilà comment il me
parlait pour médiatiser son histoire
martine a créé une association sans but
lucratif au nom de son fils l'asbl David
Collin c'est en partie grâce à elle que
tout Bastogne connait Martine et son
combat aujourd'hui elle parcourt les
rues à la rencontre des commerçants
est-ce que ça va bien ça
[Musique]
va
bonjour estce que je peux vous déranger
de petites pas de problème oui merci en
fait j'organise un vernissage avec des
des œuvres de divers artiste et un
concert en faveur de la SBL que j'ai
créé en souvenir de mon fils je pense
que vous me connaissez bien sûr et je
vais voir si je pouvais mettre une
affiche chez vous il y a pas de problème
bien sûr je la mets là là sur le je
pense c'est très très difficile et PE
courageux c'est incroyable il faut
continuer c'est oui et vous voyez quand
j'entends des personnes qui me disent
chapeau il faut continuer ben c'est ça
qui me stimule à à continuer à me
battre si tous les commerçants que
Martine rencontre la soutienent dans sa
bataille les preuves de solidarité
viennent aussi parfois
d'inconnu merci beaucoup au revoir jouré
au revoir bonjour monsieur c'est bien oh
c'est gentil merci monsieur c'est ça me
fait plaisir que vous me dites là je
vous remercie merci Monsieur au
revoir vous arrive souvent dans la rue
d'avoir des des témoignages comme ce
monsieur derrière
là là ça me touche beaucoup ça m'arrive
oui les gens qui me croisent qui me
reconnaissent surtout ils me disent
chapeau chapeau pour ton courage ça me
fait
plaisir
[Musique]
Gérard Lopez perdre un enfant est
sûrement l'épreuve la plus difficile à
surmonter mais lorsqu'il n'y a pas de
coupable à blâmer ça doit être encore
plus difficile c'est absolument
épouvantable vous savez nous avons tous
un sentiment de justice le sentiment de
justice est une chose qui fait partie de
l'homme martine a l'impression de de ne
pas pouvoir faire son deuil parce
qu'elle n'a pas obtenu justice vous
savez quand on veut se réparer quand on
est victime la première chose c'est la
reconnaissance donc vous êtes victime
d'un accident de la route la
reconnaissance elle passe aussi par la
justice il faut que la justice passe et
les victimes doivent avoir le sentiment
qu'elle est passé correctement mais
paradoxalement la recherche d'un
coupable ne permet pas forcément de
déplacer la tristesse non pas du tout il
y a une sorte de mythe que c'est après
le procès que l'on peut tourner la page
faire le deuil tout ceci c'est c'est je
crois plus des idées reçues une
idéologie que la
réalité 2 ans après la mort de David
Martine se heurte toujours à la justice
un problème auquel elle n'est pas seule
à être
confronté depuis 2 ans Stéphane est
paraplégique suite à un accident de la
route le responsable de l'accident est
un homme de 84 ans il a est condamné à 4
ans de prison avec surcis et à 10 ans de
retrait
permis grâce à une vidéo surveillance
euh la la police a pu prouver que c'est
lui qui était entièrement responsable
qu'il avait refusé la priorité j'ai
croisé deux fois au tribunal il s'est
pas excusé il m'a pas regardé il a parce
que il a aucune conscience de de ce
qu'il a
fait et pour éviter à d'autres
conducteurs rouver comme lui en fauteuil
roulant stphane fait des
conférences bonjour à
tous au côté de l'association victime et
citoyens il se rend une fois par mois
dans les collèges pour raconter son
histoire accompagné d'un autre membre de
l'association victime lui aussi d'un
accident de la
route aujourd'hui Stéphane est dans un
lycée de La banliue
Parisienne quand j'ai vu le chauffard
qui m'a coupé la route je me suis aperçu
de deux choses c'est qu'il ne savait pas
du tout les conséquences pour moi il
sait pas ce que c'est la vie en fauteuil
et il savait pas non plus quelles
seraient les conséquences pour lui il
était pas conscient qu'il risquait de la
prison de perdre le permis je pense que
avec la la la parole qu'on apporte on
peut
empêcher aux jeunes de se retrouver dans
ces deux positions de coupable et de
victime ouais vas-y c'était quoi ta
question est-ce que vous en avez voulu à
ce ce que j'en ai voulu à la personne
euh oui évidemment je pense qu'il y en a
qui doivent se dire moi ce mec-l je le
tuerai machin je le retrouve et tout je
sais très bien qui c'est je sais où il
habite cependant
euh j'ai j'ai aucun d' inérêt mais aucun
à aller le voir à essayer de d'avoir des
représailles quoi que ce soit ça
changera rien à la
vie certains lycéens restent
insensiblebles au discours de prévention
de Stéphane
difficile de toucher des jeunes de 17
ans qui rêvent de passer le
permis de des accidents
toici
réactioncci prés ettion de jeis plus Bou
jeent plus rien à partir des mamelons
plus rien du tout je pense que vous êtes
en train d'imaginer bah tout ce qui se
passe en dessous les mamelons bah il y a
les
abdos les jambes
entre
deux bah voilà il y a la vessie il y a
le sexe
bah tout ça ça marche pas des mots
durs et des images Cho dans cette vidéo
qui met en scène l'accident et la mort
de C jeunes de quoi faire prendre
conscience du danger au pluré CAL citron
tout à l'heure tu pensais que le
discours qu'on avait servait à rien à
ton avis maintenant servose parce qu'on
voyait les genstil tout et tu penses que
le discours qu'on avait avant il y avait
aucune concordance avec
ça
[Musique]
peuir peux apporter un message positif
pour leur dire qu'il faut vivre avec les
handicapés bon courage à vous Monsieur
[Musique]
Merci je vois en faisant ça que bah
finalement je j'avance j'avance je fais
je fais pas rien je sers à quelque chose
donc voilà c'est ma thérapie pour me
dire tu sers encore à quelque chose
lève-toi le matin et fais quelque chose
d'important allez à la
prochaine pètremparant vous êtes
journaliste il y a 28 ans alors que vous
rouliez de nuit sur une départementale
mouillée vous avez percuté de plein
fouet la voiture d'un couple qui arriv
en face le conducteur Philippe est
décédé et vous vous avez été condamné à
250 € d'amende 16 mois de retrait de de
permis et 2 mois de prison avec sourcis
pour homicide
involontaire vous racontez cette
histoire dans le livre un jour sur la
route j'ai tué un homme on entend
souvent le le point de vue des victimes
mais rarement celui des conducteurs qui
ont causé les accidents ce sont avant
tout des hommes et des femmes comme tout
le monde et ça peut malheureusement
arriver à tout le monde et ça peut ne
pas arriver aussi et c'est ça qui est
important et c'est le combat que je mène
aujourd'hui oui il y a des auteurs
d'accidents et et oui nous vivons
avec une souffrance aussi alors cette
souffrance elle est compliquée parce que
on la met en rapport avec la souffrance
qu'on a infligé qui est infiniment plus
grande donc parfois on a honte de cette
souffrance et c'est pour ça qu'on a une
tendance au dénis après ce qui est
compliqué pour les pour les familles des
victimes c'est que parfois refuse cette
responsabilité ne l'accepte pas ne
l'assume pas et dans les tribunaux
disent c'est pas ma faute c'est la faute
de la
voiture on voit ce jeune homme qui est
en fauteuil et le monsieur qui l'a
percuté qui ne s'est jamais excusé mais
moi ça me paraît totalement dingue
c'estàd que on est dans le cas d'un
homicide involontaire évidemment on n'a
pas fait exprès encore heureux mais
c'est une espèce de dignité et c'est
quand même un minimum de au moins
présenter ses excuses d'au moins
reconnaître sa faute à vous lire on
comprend que la véritable condamnation
c'est de vivre avec la culpabilité
oui effectivement parce que c'est
quelque chose qui ne vous quitte jamais
et puis quand on a 20 ans le sentiment
d'immortalité qu'on connaît tous à cet
âge- làà c'est c'est extrêmement
compliqué de de tout d'un coup voir que
bien non l'immortalité ça n'existe pas
et que vous êtes responsable de la mort
d'un homme donc cette culpabilité oui je
l'ai jamais j'ai simplement aujourd'hui
l'espoir de la transformer en justement
faisant la prévention routière et et et
en en parlant à haute voix pourtant nous
rallons tous lorsqu'il y a un nouveau
radar qui s'installe oui mais alors tant
qu'on a plus peur de perdre 90 € que de
perdre la vie il faut qu'il y a des
radars le problème il est là c'est la
conscience du risque routier c'estàd
qu'on rentre dans notre voiture
confortable silencieuse et puis tout
d'un coup on oublie toutes les règles de
base et ben tant qu'onarrive pas de
nous-même à se discipliner et ben il
faut qu'il y ait un rappel à la loi tout
simplement comme dans toutes les autres
délinquences sportif passionné avant son
accident Stéphane se résigne à
abandonner ses activités sportives il va
pourtant découvrir que même en fauteuil
sa passion reste
possible aujourd'hui Martine et une
dizaine de membres de son association
sont au palais de justice de Namur au
centre de la Belgique pour soutenir
Jean-Luc moi ce que j'ai écrit c'est
chauffeur briseur de vie magnifique et
justice réveille-toi c'est très bien
bien la jus
réveillee jeanl a lui aussi perdu son
fils Ry il y a 6 ans dans un accident de
la route l'automobiliste sous l'prise de
l'alcool a pris la fuite aujourd'hui
c'est l'annonce du verdict du procès du
chauffard un moment très important pour
Martine qui se sent lié au sort de
jeanluc par la
peine pour avoir une petite
un petit apaisement de la peine il faut
de la prison la prison autats-unis tu
tues quelqu'un s l'effet de la boisson
c'est minimum 10 prison du permis
i bon alors un colleçon pour attacher la
jambe Martine et jeanluc sont bien décid
à s'unir dans leur combat respectif
d'autant plus que Martine vient
d'apprendre que le dossier de son fils
risque d'être classé un coup dur pour
elle
on reste tu restes près de
moi il y a un vrai déis de victime il
m'ont même pas prévenu moi
personnellement radio TV journaux mais
moi rien mais je vais me battre et je
vais réouvrir le
dossier attends quelqu'un peut prendre
une plaque et le bonhomme s'il vous
plaît nous sommes venus pour soutenir le
papa de Rémy qui demande justice il ne
s'agit pas de vengeance mais de demander
une justice efficace qui prend en compte
la perte d'un être cher notre combat ne
fait que commencer mais nous irons
jusqu'au
bout
bra quelques heures plus tard le verdict
tombe 5 ans de prison avec surcis pour
le meurtrier de Rémy bien trop peu pour
Jean-Luc et Martin la peine est légère
elle est légère il y a pas de retraite
permis prison ferme bien sûr Ren a pas
on s'en douter mais c'est un scandale
peut-êre une justice de misère parce que
il y a eu plein d'erreurs il y a eu des
nonenquêtes il y a eu des
dysfonctionnements et CER et cetera la
lenteur de la justice fait que ce
criminel cette saloperie n'ira pas en
prison un seul jour
voilà une peine liée à l'ancienneté des
faits et à une procédure longue 3 ans et
demi d'enquête et plus d'un an de procès
ils ont ils ont enfoncé la victime he
oui ilfcé si ça avait été jugé les 2 ans
il est clair que SCI il aura pas eu le
problème juge oui mais ça le juge n'a
pas le choix avec ça pas de retrait Perm
non
c'est on va aller faire un peu du bruit
de à cause du retrait à cause du délai
irraisonnable de l'affaire à la justice
à la lenteur de la justice he quand même
le délai irraisonnable dél raisonnable
voilà ce que d à la justice de merde de
ce pays de merde 6 ans de lutte arver à
ça
ans une peine à laquelle Martine devra
peut-être faire face si le meurtrier de
son fils est
retrouvé car en Belgique après 3 ans le
dél F est
prescrit part moi David a été tué
maintenant et
MO je reste
pourver va encore avoir aussi la
prescription sur le délite fite pour moi
c'est inadmissible qu'on
tue et voilà on continue sa petite vie
bien peinard oui on a pris la fuite
parce qu'on a peur c'est quoi ça mais ça
c'est des tueurs en puissance ils
recommenceront il continuera à boire il
reprendra son volant et tueras encore il
[Musique]
continueraour à Bastogne dans la maison
voisine de Martine l'ancien domicile de
la grand-mère de David le jeune homme
avait prévu d'y emménager au moment de
son accident mortel
[Applaudissements]
oui ça me fait drôle d'entrer ici c'est
une maison
abandonnée c'est ici que Martine a
décidé de créer la maison de
David un lieu qui servira d'accueil et
de foyer temporaire à des jeunes sans
toit une main attendu par Martine et un
projet auquel elle tient énormément je
seraai peut-être un peu comme leur maman
si je peux faire quelque chose pour eux
ce que j'aurais pu faire pour mon fils
je le ferai pour d'autres en sa mémoire
oui les
aider g envie d'être comme leur maman
quelque part
oui je me sens capable de ça et faire du
bien autour de moi faire du bien rendre
des genses
heureux
ça va être la maison du bonheur pour les
jeunes et David en serait heureux j'en
suis certaine il aimait beaucoup faire
le bien autour de lui donc je suis sû
que de là où il est il est fier de ce
projet il va il il m'y aide il est
[Musique]
là bien décidé à aider un maximum de
jeunes Martine compte par la suite
ouvrir d'autres lie d'accueil dans la
région 5 ans de prison avec sourcil sans
retrait de permis pour un accident
mortel sous l'emprise de l'alcool et
avec des lit F c'est effectivement très
peu on peut comprendre la colère de la
famille on comprend la colère de la
famille ce qui est surtout je crois très
frustrant dans ce dossier c'est la
longueur du procès donné à quelqu'un 5
ans après un accident 5 ans de prison ça
n'a plus de sens et donc une justice qui
n'a plus de sens Ben est une justice qui
tourne à vide pourquoi la justice est
aussi clémente avec les responsables
d'accident de la route pourquoi les
peines sont si faible parce qu'on est
dans un concept de blessure involontaire
ou d'homicide involontaire et que dans
ce cas-là le code pénal le prévoit pas
des peines très lourdes alors c'est sûr
qu'il faudrait peut-être trouver un
délit qui dit qu'une personne qui était
complètement négligeent sur un certain
nombre de critères que ce soit le le le
soin de de son véhicule que ce soit
l'addiction aux drogues licite ou
illicite que qu' soit dans un excès de
vitesse et cetera qu'il soit au-delà si
vous voulez simplement de la blessure
involontaire tel qu'elle est
actuellement ou l'homicide involontaire
tel qu'elle est actuellement caractérisé
par le code pénal la répression est-elle
la seule
solution la répression est une des
solutions il faut toujours articuler
l'information
euh la prévention et la répression mais
il faut articuler les trois et peut-être
pour le moment n'y a-t-il pas assez de
prévention et n'y a-t-il pas assez
d'information vous pensez qu'il faudrait
faire comme d'autres pays et mettre le
taux d'alcool à absolument pour
commencer peut-être pour
commencer aujourd'hui comme deux fois
par mois Stéphane prend le volant d'un
carart qui comme sa voiture est adaptée
à son
handicap
le
frein
l'accélérateur je m'y suis fait en en me
donnant les moyens
euh de faire tout ce que j'ai envie de
faire voilà j'ai j'ai voulu essayer le
ski je me suis donné les moyens de
d'aller d'aller dans une station de ski
avec une association et je me fixe
aucune limite euh dans ce que j'ai envie
de faire j'ai envie de faire du kayak
sur la scène et ben je vais trouver une
façon de faire du kayak sur la
scène tennis natation ski et même box
Stéphane touche à toutes les disciplines
en dis sport aujourd'hui il est venu
partager un moment de plaisir avec son
père sur la piste et Stéphane va même
lui donner des petits
conseils pr plus
large plus
l et pour St accélérateur à fond ça
passe oh merde ou ça
casse B alors c'est pas une toureuse bah
ouais je sais pas foutu ça c'est gaz
trop fort trop braqué forcément ça fait
pas bon ménage pourtant elle partait
bien
j'ai pas le même rapport au danger que
j'avais avant avant j'étais peut-être
moins conscient du danger en fait mais
bon le danger il peut venir de partout
qu'on soit en moto en vélo à pied ou en
voiture faut juste je pense juste qu'il
faut être conscient du danger
euh et voilà affronter la vie en étant
conscient du danger alors c petite virée
B sympa ça glisse un peu sous la pluie
mais mais bon ça fait toujours
plaisir quand on est dans le quart c'est
comme si on était valide quoi il y a la
même on a les mêmes
sensations on joue sur le même terrain
donc on est égo quoi je vais regarder
mon score intéressant les rours une 14
et
Ben et il faudra faire mieux car dans
quelques jour a lieu une course de
carartte ouvert à tous valide et
invalide l'équipe de Stéphane vient de
le rejoindre elle sera exclusivement
composé d'amis eux aussi en fauteuil
roulant mais là faut qu'on s'y prépare
parce c'est au mois de novembre c'est le
30 novembre motiv apparemment ah bah
ouais on est inscrit déjà ah d'accord ah
ouais ou mais il il a assez de monde ou
pas bah oui ça va le faire plus de M
c'est pas grave c'est pas
grave c'est pas parce qu'on a un
accident de moto qu'il faut arrêter les
sport mécanique ça rien à voir quoi
c'est c'est un préjugé que de dire j'ai
eu un accident de moto donc plus de
sport mécanique il y a il y a aucun
rapport entre les deux quoi aujourd'hui
Stéphane prend les choses avec
philosophie ce qui est plus difficile
pour son père ça va parce qu'il fait
beaucoup d'activité maintenant est-ce
que réellement ça va bien intérieurement
ça je peux pas vous dire aujourd'hui je
peux pas vous dire encore il s'occupe
beaucoup s'occupe beaucoup alors est-ce
que c'est pas justement pour cacher
quelque chose ça on peut pas savoir
voilà al est-ce que nous on espère que
non que ça va réellement bien mais
est-ce que ça peut aller bien quand on
est
de
voilà seul seul lui peut le
dire disons que je vais bien euh
comparer à d'autres
euh j'habite j'habite avec ma chérie
j'arrive à m'occuper quasiment tous les
jours en faisant du sport ou d'autres
activités avec les associations
après psychologiquement c'est c'est
difficile en fait dans dans les temps
morts de ma journée où je me vois en
fauteuil ou avant mon accident je voyais
mon avenir était tout tracé en fait je
me voyais ma carrière je voyais je
voyais ma vie dans une maison avec des
enfants
euh aujourd'hui quand j'essaie de penser
à mon avenir en fait je vois le
fauteuil comment je vais faire en étant
en fauteuil pour avoir des enfants
j'imagine beaucoup moins l'avenir je vis
beaucoup plus au jour le jour
[Musique]
qu'avant Martine Stéphane leur vie a
basculé en quelques secondes blessé dans
leur chair chacun tente de se
reconstruire lui à travers la volonté de
reprendre une vie active
elle avec l'espoir de retrouver le
chauffard qui a tué son
[Musique]
fils je pourrais dire David tu peux
reposer enfin ton âme en paix maman a
trouvé celui qui t'a tué tu peux partir
l'me en paix et ça c'est tout ce qui me
reste à
espérer on pourrait me souhaiter que que
je retrouve l'usage de mes Jens mais
mais ça c'est utopique
et faut pas s'arrêter là-dessus faut
c'est pas ce qu'il faut espérer euh donc
simplement que je vive normalement que
que j'ai une
vie riche riche en
émotion